Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So we need to talk about your last Vlogbrothers
video, and not the one where the Gregory Brothers
songified our fight about Batman, the one
before that where you talked about...
I actually don't remember what you talked
about because I was too focused on this.
So Hank, Nerdfighter reviews of your new hair
cut were universally positive, but then again,
Nerdfighteria is a very supportive and loving
community, whereas I am your brother.
Hank, in my my life I've had three major hair
styles.
For about the past fifteen years I've had
some variation of short on the sides, messy
up top.
Before that, for many years I had a hair cut
called "The Junior Senator from Maryland"
and then of course there was my original hair
cut "Toad from Mario Kart."
Meanwhile Hank, your entire life you've had
just the one hair style, which I call The
Hank, I can't even describe the exact properties
of The Hank to you because it just is.
It's like trying to describe water to a fish.
"The Hank" is that which sits atop Hank's
head.
And then suddenly, change!
Unannounced, radical change!
Now Hank as you know, I'm not a huge fan of
change.
I just think change is tremendously overrated.
People are always like: "Life is change!"
And that's true, but you know what else is
change?
Death.
But Hank, your hairstyle change upset me particularly
because it reminded me a little bit of Kennedy's
haircut.
You know, the left-back of the AFC Wimbledon
Wimbly Womblys, the fictional soccer team
I play FIFA 14 with.
Now Hank I realize when it comes to hair I
live in the glassiest of glass houses, but
I've been throwing rocks at Kennedy's hair
for years now.
And then, suddenly, my own brother adopts
a version of The Kennedy.
Well Hank, this led to a bit of an existential
crisis.
Now Hank, admittedly, these days it doesn't
take much to point me in the direction of
an existential crisis, but I started thinking
about my brother, who is a real person in
real life I really like, and then there's
Kennedy, a very talented, but fictional, left-back
who's technically made out of pixels.
But now in my head they're connected, so anything
I say about Kennedy's hair I'm sort of implying
about your hair.
And the whole thing just made me think about
how nothing that happened in one's so called
"virtual life" could ever be fully disconnected
from what happens in your so called "real
life", right?
I think realness might be more of like a continuum
than an actual thing, you know?
Like ultimately, self-hood and relationships
and experiences and FIFA playing and whatever
else are varying degrees of real rather than
simply real or not.
Like Hank, in my life there are two AFC Wimbledons,
right?
There are the AFC Wimbledon Wimbly Womblys
a fictional FIFA team who have worked their
way up from League Two and are now enjoying
their first season in the Premier League,
and it's going great because Bald John Green
and Other John Green, our two strikers, have
found renewed form since the adoption of their
baby boy JJ.
And that whole Wimbly Wombly world is to quote
Severus Snape "Real for Us", us being the
weird and lovely people who support the Wimbly
Womblys.
And then we use the ad revenue from that series
to sponsor the other AFC Wimbledon, you know,
the real one.
That AFC Wimbledon is an actual professional
Soccer team in England, but it started 13
years ago from nothing except a bunch of fans
who had the idea to make a soccer team.
The fact that imagination and work can make
ideas real is what finally resolved this existential
crisis, because it's like the most beautiful
and lovely thing about life to me.
The whole thing just made me want to support
AFC Wimbledon more if we can, so I'm gonna
try to do more video gaming stuff.
I've, started a Twitch TV channel, and even
though I don't really know how it works I'm
gonna try broadcasting today.
There's a link in the doobly-doo.
So basically Hank, your new haircut made me
think about what's real and what's not real
and how much I admire people like you and
the founders of AFC Wimbledon for working
so hard to make awesome things real.
And then I was like, you know what?
I kind of like Hank's new haircut, which,
by extension means that I guess now I kinda
like Kennedy's haircut in FIFA.
This was a very weird Vlogbrothers video.
I will see you on Friday.